[Musique]
les commémorations du 8 mai 45 fin de la
seconde guerre mondiale se sont
déroulées sans public
emmanuel macron c'est tout d'abord
recueilli sur les champs-elysées à paris
devant la statue du général de gaulle
avant de présider la cérémonie sous
l'arc de triomphe en présence du premier
ministre jean castex et de la mer de la
capitale anne hidalgo dépôt de gerbe au
pied de la flamme du soldat inconnu
avant une minute de silence puis la
marseillaise chantée a cappella le mois
de mai nous rend heureux et joué que ça
mais il ya une ambiance du tonnerre
alors du coup je suis c'est une question
facile jeux sont là à commencer par si
vous donner la bonne réponse vous m'en
passer oui devant une question
pas droit
les membres assez on n'a pas le droit en
coulisses quand personne n'ouvrait
heureusement quand le sperme est au
centre du monde vous avez pris un truc
tout à l'heure si je gagne 2 oui je vais
boire
oui monsieur godard c'est très sympa
parce qu'on va bientôt en fait seul et
ses avantages
agoda y est c'est un nom qui sert à
faire des choses c'est encore une nounou
narry good eye c'est une fête joyeuse et
arrosez très bien c'est pour bientôt et
on a entendu que le conseil scientifique
disait qu éventuellement cet été il
pourrait y avoir une quatrième vague
donc l'espoir c'est effectivement un de
réussir le déconfinement 2 de faire la
preuve qu'on a fait aussi bien voire
mieux que les autres et non pas moins
bien comme un certain nombre de
politiques le disent notamment de
l'opposition
ils sont tous en manque de spectacle
vivant voilà regarde les symboles du
crash de la culture à cause de la crise
sanitaire cet avion est aussi un signe
d'espoir celui de la reprise des
représentations où le public réapprend
dans cette pièce quelques gestes
essentiels comme rire est tout
simplement applaudir alors j'avance
c'est fini un jour c'est la baisse ses
masques et c'est terminé
mais c'était alors je m'adresse déjà aux
complotistes qui nous écoutent ils
avaient raison ça a été inventé et les
personnes décédées ont re a fait ça au
montage c'est un acte de résistance
pacifique on n'a pas le droit d'aller au
théâtre mais on a le droit de prendre
l'avion donc on n'a pas vendu des
billets de théâtre on a vendu des
billets d'avions alors c'est de l'humour
mais en même temps ça a du sens cet
embarquement anticipé vient
symboliquement remplacer le festival de
théâtre qui se tient dans la commune
chaque année annulé pour la deuxième
fois
vous seriez me refaire le sourire
américain de sourire hollywoodien alors
si le sourire justement que
bernard-henri n'aime pas on n'est
surtout pas de sourire hollywoodien
il est comme ça à voilà parce que si on
pourrait le jeu d'acteur et je suis là
dans mes clips non mais vous mêmes ou
parce que j'étais là non mais ça me fait
trop mal au coeur et tous et leur que
jamais a pris dans ses bras
à fès coûteuses ou bien ce jeu trop bien
nous avions au préalable chacun avait
choisi une petite peluche qu'il avait
légèrement évident est de retirer de
l'intérieur avec des élastiques couleur
chair des gens installés mais mais
quelle horreur
vous avez manqué peluches des animaux
vivants oui vous avez pas emballé un
animal ou un cow boy
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aidons et vous vous étiez dans donkey
c'est une très très bonne question je ne
sais plus je ne sais pas vous rentrer
n'importe où sans savoir chez qui vous
êtes fan de tâter août et et j'essaye de
traiter le a est sorti c'est moi qui les
donnait d'ailleurs bah voilà léon
l'acceptent dîner en tête à tête avec
robert ans qu'est ce que c'est
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ça dîner en
tête à tête avec robert tu étais une
repas se fait en silence
une tradition que les mennonites
perpétue depuis des siècles au menu des
haricots
une simple soupe de légumes et des
saucisses ils vivent comme au 19ème
siècle toujours appris qu'en tant
qu'homme je devais faire des tâches
domaine j'espère que mon binôme elle
aussi a été levée avec ses valeurs
traditionnelles qu'elle fera des choses
de filles comme la cuisine ce genre de
choses ce serait formidable
selon la bible pour accéder au paradis
nous ne devons pas être en contact avec
les choses modernes comme la télé le
téléphone et l'ordinateur ou la voiture
nous a toujours appris à refuser la
modernité
tu as voulu jouer tu as perdu bon j'ai
toujours mal mais je suis surtout
généreux non mais je suis fait pourquoi
tu fais ça
jusque là les deux derniers en irak qui
ça c'est intéressant de le savoir il ya
un bébé qui naît avec 3 pénis et une
première monde sait jamais une
intéressante à ce niveau là il faut plus
de slip c'est une paire de gants qu'il
faut mais ça vous laisse sur cette image
poétique est ce possible de venir avec
vous à l'église et de fines et la caméra
n'est pas autorisée car les gens d'avoir
peur et les femmes enceintes peuvent
tomber malades a fait qu à cause de la
caméra y'a parce qu'elles ont peur elles
ne sont pas habitués si vous alliez vous
présenter auprès des plus jeunes vous
diriez je suis avocat je dirais je suis
un mammouth
vous êtes un mammouth oui vous savez je
suis socialiste des éléphants moi je
suis dans la catégorie déjà au dessus
la version diffusée à mamoudzou voilà